معذرة، هل لديك
حلم كان
حلما، أي حلم يتكرر أو يشبه إلى حد كبير ما
تريد أن يحدث
في الحياة أو ما ترغب في تحقيقه في
الحياة، نعم الآن، أود أن
تتوقف إسرائيل عن إزعاج
غزة  هذه طريقة جيدة لأنني
أعتقد أن الأمر سيكون صعبًا
لأنك شخص غير أناني للغاية
وتفكر في الآخرين طوال
الوقت. لا أستطيع أن أقول لا، نعم، أعني أن
حلمك يمكن أن يكون حول ما تحصل عليه.  على
منصتي أحاول
تحقيق أحلام الناس، لست متأكدًا من أنني أستطيع تحقيق
هذا الحلم ولكني أحب حقيقة
أن فكرتك الأولى تدور حول مساعدة
الآخرين، هل كنت دائمًا على هذا
النحو، لا كيف أصبحت بهذه الطريقة؟
أليس هذا مجرد ما يدور
في ذهني كثيرًا في الوقت الحالي
لأنه مجرد
ما يحدث، هذا مجرد
رأيي،
لذا نعم، أنت تعلم أن هذا رائع، أتمنى أن
يصبح حلمك حقيقة، هناك بعض
الأحلام التي يمكنني تحقيقها.  يمكن أن أساعد في
تحقيق بعض الأحلام، هناك أحلام أخرى
لا أستطيع تحقيقها ولكني أتمنى حقًا أن يتحقق
حلمك، شكرًا
لمشاركته معي، لا بأس بذلك، من دواعي
سروري